bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir
emmanuel macron sort du silence sur
l'islam politique en déplacement dans
l'est
le chef de l'état s'attaque au
séparatisme islamistes terme qu'il
préfère au communautarisme et au delà
des mots il vient d'annoncer une série
de mesures à commencer par la lutte
contre l' ingérence des puissances
étrangères dans le financement des lieux
de culte ou encore l'organisation de
l'islam la reconquête républicaine est
elle en marche c'est le thème de notre
grand débat ce soir là pierre griveau a
braqué les projecteurs sur un phénomène
qui fait de plus en plus de victimes le
revenge porn la publication de contenus
intime sur une personne sans son
consentement qui touche ce prono de la
vengeance comment lutter contre la loi
est-elle suffisante et les réseaux
sociaux sont ils responsables
décryptage à suivre sur ce plateau et
puis notre grand témoin ce soir n'a pas
sa langue dans sa poche ce qui est
plutôt rare dans le petit monde de la
magistrature hilare qui pendant vingt
ans aux assises de paris aujourd'hui
il préside l'institut de la parole
philippe bilger est avec nous ce soir
voilà donc pour le programme c'est parti
hashtags vr n'oubliez pas on l'a
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs
merci d'avoir choisi lcp nos invités en
plateau ce soir philippe bilger bonsoir
fois merci d'être notre grand témoin on
va passer une heure mais quelles charges
vous allez voir ça va très bien se
passer vous êtes magistrat avocat
général à la cour d'assises de paris
pendant plus de vingt ans vous animez
aujourd'hui un blog à saint flour il
s'appelle justice au singulier et une
émission sur sud radio et vous écrivait
des livres dont le dernier le mur dès
qu'on est sorti chez albin michel en
octobre dernier
on va parler de la sphère griveaux qui
vous a inspiré une tribune récente dans
le figaro mais d'abord ce mot de
séparatisme islamiste qu'a retenu
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui dans l'est
et son plan d'action qu'il vient en
partie de détails et il y à moins d'une
heure maintenant on en parle avec vous
nadia est bonsoir vous êtes député la
république en marche des yvelines de
trappes notamment eric diard bonsoir
bonsoir députés les républicains des
bouches du rhône coauteur d'un rapport
remarqué sur la radicalisation dans les
services publics on en dira un mot
alexis corbière bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes député la france insoumise de
seine saint denis et georges malbrunot
le grand reporter au figaro et
spécialiste du moyen-orient va nous
rejoindre dans un instant merci à tous
de participer à ce ça vous regarde en
direct je vous donne la parole
mais c'est des femmes comme tous les
soirs qui ouvre le bal stéphane
blakowski et son business et j'ai bien
compris
[Musique]
à tous tout âge et à tous pardon comme
dit le président alors si j'ai bien
compris ce soir alors si j'ai bien
compris et myriam vous l'avait déjà
annoncé ça y est c'est décidé cette fois
le président macron va se battre lutter
contre le séparatisme alors qu'est ce
que c'est que le séparatisme et là il
faut bien préciser c'est un bon un peu
nouveau donc avancer le nouveau mot
quand je vois le président en fait pour
dénoncer le développement d'un islam
politique dans certains quartiers donc
l'idée au départ c'est que quand on
parle du communautarisme c'est un peu
embêtant parce que les communautés elles
peuvent effectivement se regrouper
autour de leurs craintes leurs
traditions leurs croyances leur religion
ça pose aucun problème en définitive là
où sa grande s'impose à un problème
c'est pour ça qu'on a choisi un nouveau
mot séparatisme c'est quand une
communauté je vais pas me faire passer
ses lois soit religieuse ou je sais pas
quoi vous traditionnel au dessus des
lois
la république c'est pour ça qu'on parle
de séparatisme alors qu'est ce que ça
change cette cette nuance sémantique bas
je suis ça change grand chose on en
parlera mais disons que ça marquait une
évolution de la part du président
m'accroche et je passe si vous souvenez
en 2018 en mars il y avait une tribune
publiée dans le figaro
santes intellectuelle qui avait dit non
au séparatisme islamistes à l'époque
c'était benjamin griveaux était porte
parole du gouvernement il avait dit moi
je me soutient pas cette tribune je la
trouve trop stigmatisant donc depuis les
choses ont un peu changé
pas seulement pour benjamin griveaux
mais aussi pour les positions du
président sur la la question est dès
novembre au congrès des maires il avait
clairement par les dénoncer ce
séparatisme
sans employer le mot mais on comprend
bien ce qu'il dénonce dans certaines
communes dans certains quartiers
progresse depuis quelques années un
projet de séparation d'avec la
république
c'est une réalité ce sont les
revendications sur les horaires réservés
aux femmes dans les piscines
ces espaces publics où la mixité n'est
plus possible
ce sont ces pressions exercées dans
certains services publics
certaines entreprises se sont aussi des
services communautaires qui cherchent à
se substituer à la république et lady
scolarisation d'enfants auxquels on
assiste dans trop d'écoles
apparemment c'est devenu la priorité du
président la lutte contre le séparatisme
alors la priorité des priorités du
président jacques aymes de se faire
élire en 2022 si on veut vraiment mettre
aussi commencer par la vérité mais
justement si les tags de 49 ans parce
que on a vu qu'il avait piqué les
électeurs à droite aux européennes en
apparaissant comme le champion de l'ue
combat contre l'islamisme le séparatisme
islamistes évidemment il peut séduire
cet électorat d'ailleurs on voit qu'il
est très présent sur le sujet dont je
vous ai fait une petite revue de presse
dans le parisien que j'ai choisi journal
populaire la 1er janvier en liga annonce
du plan contre le communautarisme
à l'époque on n'est pas encore changer
de vocabulaire 6 février alors cette
fois ci marque on veut marquer le coup
contrôle que motta rythme mais attention
toutes les semaines il se passe quelque
chose
la semaine suivante et il est prêt à
abattre ses cartes contre le
communautarisme mais il est très très
présent sur le sujet puis à enfin
aujourd'hui donc on s'est mis au jour
avec le nouveau mot cette fois-ci
aujourd'hui le parisien annonce que il
ya un plan contre le séparatisme qui est
le nouveau mot comme un maquereau vous
allez me dire que ça ressemble un peu à
de la communication tout ça enfin je
vais vous dire je vous rappeler plutôt
que la base de la pédagogie c'est la
répétition et donc que le gouvernement a
manqué de pédagogie donc là ils répètent
ils répètent et donc voilà il ya
aujourd'hui des mesures qui ont été
annoncées à mulhouse on va en parler
mais de la semaine prochaine il va faire
un nouveau déplacement pour enlever une
part non c'est une nouvelle série de
mesures va être très présent sur le
front de la lutte contre le séparatisme
islamistes pas faire de mal avant les
des justes est les municipales alors
qu'est ce qu'il a dit aujourd'hui
quelles sont les premières séries de
mesures il a fait un bilan je reviens en
tant qu en a déjà qui l'avaient déjà
fait les choses il a surtout si
aujourd'hui sur les ingérences
étrangères des pays dont qui favorisent
ce séparatisme
en france on que à mulhouse il ya un
acompte content de voir arriver à
georges malbrunot l'amusé amour qui
était financé par le qatar comme l'a
révélé son livre mais à d'autres aspects
d'ingérence irina une agence qui l'a
dénoncée dans le cadre des
établissements scolaires depuis 77 en
france les enfants d'émigrés peuvent
suivre des cours facultatifs pour leur
langue et leur culture origine sauf que
les profs de ces cours sont dénoncés
sont nommés par l'étranger est ce que
c'est une bonne idée de l'esr de gan
nommer les profs en france donc pas
croire dit non à la rentrée ça sera
super ça sera supprimé il a aussi dit
qu'il ferait plus attention pareil
recrutement des imams éviter que ça
passe par l'étrange donc il a pris ce
genre de mesures vont rouvrir le débat
juste
j'ai entendu dans son discours qu'il y
avait beaucoup pris de précautions
attention sur
tous ne pas stigmatiser ne pas montrer
les musulmans du doigt donc je pose une
question éventuellement comment se
fait-il que la russie et puis construire
en plein coeur de paris une grande
cathédrale orthodoxe qui a coûté je
crois que plus de 100 millions d'euros
et que ça soit impossible pour le qatar
de construire une grande mosquée
mulhouse vouloir toujours faire une idée
là le sens de la provocation ali pour
vous cette saison parce que j'aurai
qu'on commence avec vous georges
malbrunot on peut commencer d'ailleurs
par la réponse à la question on y va je
pense qu'ils ce qui diffère fait qu'il
ya peut-être un peu de prosélytisme de
la part des bailleurs de fonds qatariens
prosélytisme qui vise l'islam politique
voilà alors la russie bon la vieille
russie comme spécialiste des ingérences
dans le domaine religieux qui sont quand
même là une bonne base religieuse à
paris comme elle l'a on est dans
l'ingérence religieux zaïri là il a cité
la turquie est le cas il n'a pas cité le
qatar mais il n'a pas cité le qatar et
il est allé dans une ville à mulhouse où
la grande mosquée très belle mosquée
flambant neuf de de mulhouse est financé
par le qatar il n'avait pas invité à ce
déplacement
en tout cas pas sur l'ensemble des
séquences les représentants de cette
mosquée est ce que vous pouvez nous
décrypter ce choix là il a parlait quand
même dans sa conférence de presse
d'abord de manière assez assez forte
il a parlé de malaise il a parlé que
effectivement il y avait des
financements étrangers qui devait c 'est
il n'a pas volu stigmatiser le qatar le
qatar via kata charité finances pour moi
de ne pas me fâcher que le qatar parce
que voilà autant fait ce qui a aussi des
intérêts commerciaux politiques de qatar
c'est notre allié le monde y met des
limites et il en a mis en particulier à
l'égard de la turquie
d'ailleurs quitte parce que la turquie
non la mule aux mes parents à strasbourg
est la faute des mecs qui est bien est
en train via un groupe qui s'appelle
milli gorus de construire une immense
mosquée d'un budget d'environ 26
millions d'euros
par conséquent effectivement il faut il
faut mettre des limites à cette
ingérence extérieure d'ingérence
on a géré en silence
éthique alors qu'ils financent quand
même influence un petit peu quand même
et puis dans le cas de qatar charité
éducateurs ce qu'on avait démontré dans
notre livre c'est qu'à travers les 140
centres islamiques mosquée est financé
par kata charité en europe
99 % des bénéficiaires de l'aide était
des associations comme celle d'amran aux
lié aux frères musulmans dont un islam
politique partisan justement de cet
islam globale et là on retrouve dans la
mosquée an nour ce qu emmanuel macron a
dit quand on a visité avec nasser al al
qadi et le responsable d'al amal dit
nous avons une salle de prière pour les
hommes une sobre pour les femmes c'est
très bien nous avons des salles de
classe nous avons un sauna nous avons un
crossfit
nous avons une morgue et c'est donc
c'est cette conception de cette
constitution de l'an d'années qui pose
problème
il faut construire des mosquées pour les
musulmans pour qu'ils puissent que aller
prier de manière décente à mulhouse ils
ne l'ont pas toujours cette possibilité
mais il faut pas que ce soit des
mosquées centre de vie dans lequel dans
lesquelles un islam politique soit
diffusée et soit près du quai parce que
là on sort du cadre de la loi de la
république et balançant cela qu emmanuel
macron a voulu tracer à mettre des
limites sur les soirs quand même des
enseignants parce qu'il a dit
effectivement les del cerro d
enseignement c'est que mes enfants qui
aujourd'hui c'est au coeur qu'on
accueille depuis longtemps il fallait y
mettre un terme tôt ou tard halak et
nous passer avec ce qui vient du coran
ce pendant le ramadan qui viennent du
maroc d'algérie d'arabie séoudite
parfois et donc il fallait y mène à y
mettre un terme
dans ces écoles la danse et
d'enseignement l'a parfois les
enseignants ne parle pas le français
ça pouvait pas durer deux logiques c'est
bien bon sens ce suppression de l'esam
consulaires en fait c'est non c'est pas
la suppression parce que le maroc si des
images est intéressant dans l'eau
le discours de macron c'est qu'on a bien
vu que l'algérie et le maroc joue la
carte macrophages veut dire là
clairement pointé du doigt la turquie
alors que la mère bientôt ils coopèrent
alors que la turquie ne coopèrent pas et
pourquoi pressés à ce que parce que la
turquie et la france ont des relations
extrêmement tendues macron erdogan et
puis la turquie concédant une et bien
moi j'avais six cent mille français
d'origine turque eux d'ailleurs il ya
une alliance politique avec le qatar il
faut être vigilant parce que quand on
revient à la mosquée de strasbourg de
milli gorus et un hammam un monsieur de
cette mosquée qui est allé avec un
fonctionnaire de la municipalité de
strasbourg qui est allé à l'automne
dernier au qatar à koweit ramasser de
l'argent alors ces permis par le
concordat
mais dans la conjoncture actuelle s'est
imposée problèmes mais là c'est tout ça
qu'il faut revoir et qu'il commença en
tout cas pointer et a touché je rappelle
que vous êtes l'auteur avec christian
chesnot de qatar peppers comment l
émirat finances l'islam de france et
d'europe c'est aux éditions michel lafon
pour aller plus loin question sur cette
question de l'ingérence de puissances
étrangères qu'est ce que vous dites
bravo enfin c'est trop tard
où ça n'est pas le sujet eric diard non
je vous dirai pas je dirais passé je
dirais quand même enfin voila ma si la
france je dirais enfin parce qu'il
fallait agir
on l'a vu vous l'avez viennent présenter
ça allait venir ils allaient abattre les
cartes ça fait presque ça fait plus d'un
an qu'on attendait des décisions alors
sur le corps iota risme religieux alors
maintenant il veut appeler ça c'est
parti pour moi c'est de la sémantique
moi quand je pense séparatisme jeu
historiquement c'était le séparatisme
breton le le séparatisme corse alors il
veut appeler ça le séparatisme est pour
moi le communautarisme religieux
c'est une forme de repli identitaire
alors il ya des bonnes propositions pour
le rapporteur des services publics face
à la radicalisation faudra que j'attende
encore parce que j'ai compris que tout
était très feuilletonner que ça allait
durer le feuilleton chez pas ça sera pas
les deux amours les ce qu'il est dans
son rôle pour vous le président de la
rép oui les danseurs dans un scrutin il
y dix ans il avait un scooter presque t
il ya toujours des scrutins donc je
pense quand même qu'il y avait des
propositions intéressantes par poser le
co et la mettre en place et yeux n
qui remplacera colin les enseignements
des landes dans la culture d origine
dans la main d'origine m ça c'était
intéressant il reste ya ça sera une loi
il est resté quand même assez vagues sur
le financement des mosquées et georges
malbrunot à bien si c'est sur quelque
chose d'important
le financement de la salle de prière ces
dangers sa légitime il était gêné
notamment sur le financement d'une
piscine parce que ce qu'est ce qui
voulait dire à travers ça une piscine ça
sera des des horaires aménagés pour pour
les femmes et cetera tard et les jeux et
les valeurs de la bière qui ne seront
pas respectées dans ce centre alexis
corbière que l'état puisse mettre son
nez dans le financement des lieux de
culte et des mosquées pour les nommer
c'est une bonne chose
attention parce que la laïcité qui
s'exprime notamment dans la loi du 9
décembre 1905 c'est pas le con colonne
napoléon s'est pas l'état qui regarde
après il faut faire respecter la loi ça
a été rappelée kantien l'église
orthodoxe qui est construit c'était des
bâtiments météo france et nicolas
sarkozy dans canada accords politiques
pour faire plaisir monsieur poutine qui
accepte que une puissance étrangère au
coeur de paris etc une vue magnifique
construisent un lieu de culte la loi ne
peut pas être à géométrie rajhi
paperasse musique était très intéressant
mais ça peut pas être ça dépend ce qui
s'y passe iliad influence ou pas moi je
suis pour la laïcité par géométrie
variable soit n'y a pas de financement
de puissances étrangères de lieux de
culte soit il ya des possibilités
d'accord le cadre des mosquées vous
savez bien que c'est hors de question
des mosquées et de l'islam en france
elle est compliquée parce que au moment
où la loi a été votée en 1905 il n'y
avait pas autant de musulmans
donc c'est le sujet non mais là je
comprends pas ce que je serais pose la
question est ce que là est ce que l'état
doit avoir le contrôle sur la
construction des mosquées non-pays clic
le 1 et 2 qui noyautent sans eau à 1905
pas de financement public des religions
alors évidemment à partir de là les
contrôles j'ai dit j'ai pas dit
forcément de ferries s'est passé votre
âge à la loi la police les services de
l'état doivent vérifier ce qui se passe
dans un établissement lui l'enjeu c'est
quoi c'est la lutte contre
l'obscurantisme contre le fait ça a été
définie tout à l'heure que les lois de
la république ne serait pas respectée
par des citoyens au nom de dogmes
religieux non discutable bon ça c'est
clair mais ça la loi existe d'ores et
déjà quelqu'un qui dans n'importe quel
lieu de culte dans une mosquée un imam
qui tiendra un propos on dit
en jean sérien les femmes sont
inférieures aux hommes où je vous invite
à fêter votre épouse à la maison
évidemment il doit être sanctionné et
c'est ça la loi peut le faire alors on
peut même discuté du fait qu'aux médias
n'ont les moyens là on attendait là où
il ya des possibilités sur les imams
certains son annexe au ciel je dirais
que la question des des paysages
étranges avis mais attention aux côtés
cendre de bois tous ces discussions le
qatar dont on a donné le nom ça
principal outil de diplomatie très
important s'appelle le paris
saint-germain d'accord il a envie toutes
les périodes et ancien président de la
république à ksar non non non oui jma
lis beaucoup plus amusant mais vous avez
bien dit quoi ya une hypocrisie de la
france vis-à-vis des actionnaires
nous venons d armand l'arabie saoudite y
compris qui est engagée dans un conflit
au lieu dit aucune sympathie et en
double à 17,36 etc
et si on dit qu'il ya une ingérence dans
la vie politique économique du kata ce
que je pensais être à dire un peu de
méthode
les 14 les frères musulmans il faut
expliquer parce que des gens
s'accaparent le pays qui sponsorise je
dirais le les frères musulmans depuis un
certain temps on l'a vu en tunisie on
l'a vu en egypte et a des relations des
liens d'ailleurs avec l'ex udf en france
mais pour répond pour jouer vous poser
une question
moi je suis allé à stresa mulot j'ai vu
nassir al qadi le responsable de la
mosquée viry prier dans des caves et ces
gens là ils sont français comme vous et
moi ils ont droit à avoir des salles de
prière non mais qui finance si on peut
pas si l'état français ne finance pas lé
vous bien qu'ils aillent
je vais là les fidèles ça suffit pas
comme ça suffit ça peut suffire leur
combat ils vont nous donner des pays du
mois ça ne me choque pas déjà c'est des
fidèles qui veut financer ludo culte
je ne suis pas pour toucher à ça alors
les fidèles je connais bien ça moi
bagnolet montreuil il ya des
associations déjà y récoltent de
l'argent ne faiblit pas mais ça met tout
de même ne racontons pas non plus ça
participe aussi à ce que de plus en plus
ce que tu en as plus n'est pas l'islam
des caves et de est quasiment voie de
disparition il ya des lieux de culte qui
est ensuite et ça ne me choque pas que
parfois mais ça doit être contrôlé et
s'il ya un homme d'affaires marocain
alger
rien qui participent à ça je ne vois pas
comment on peut l'interdire par contre
que l'on surveille que ce soit pas des
circuits financiers criminels etc et que
surtout il n'est pas après un discours
politique anti républicain christiane ça
je suis poète vigilant mais par contre
je sais pas c'est ça que vous pointiez
et je voulais quand même souligner que
pendant deux d'aller vite mais tout ça
se passe à mulhouse la houle et la
laïcité n'est pas respectée en france
dire que ce que vous avez évoqué des
valeurs colère d'un concordat en raison
du retard c'est le maire dans la mairie
de mulhouse qui aurait participé au
financement de ce lieu de culte
ça ça me choque et emmanuel macron ne le
dénoncent pas donc tout ça évidemment
des opérations de politiciens à 305
élections pour changer la conversation
aujourd'hui la question et sociale les
retraites et comme par hasard aux dames
et puis je dire vous l'aurais après
nadia est là dessus je les aime que
voilà pour répondre à l'excès de poids
deux mesures j'en ai tous vus répondre
ah non mais justement soit soient vos
propos sont complètement hypocrite soit
vous ne savez pas ce qui se passe
réellement mercier dans les mosquées
je vous ai dit mon propos ne faisais pas
je vais pas parler de vos propos sont
hypocrites ou alors vous ne savez pas ce
qui s'y passe
évidemment que les financements qui
arrivent de l'étranger ont une certaine
ingérence qui est exercée dans les pays
étrangers en fonction du pays qui
finance vous avez tel ou tel courant qui
s'exerce dans telle ou telle mosquée et
quoi alors on était libre il marais du
ca la filière dinde il ya effectivement
dans il ya des sujets aujourd'hui sur le
financement du culte et il suffit enfin
là il s'agit d'inscrire le financement
des lieux de culte dans le droit commun
aujourd'hui n'importe quel particulier
ne peut pas recevoir une certaine somme
d'argent qu'elle vienne d'arabie
saoudite qu'elle vienne du qatar sans
qu'elles soient justifiées et sans que
l'origine des fonds le soit également
donc c'est d'inscrire tout simplement
les financements de lieux de sa veux
dire quoi ils avaient droit d'interroger
duel sur le causse noir financement mais
les pièces jaunes et une forme la
question dans les annonces faites par le
président de la république d'arrêter
tout financement du culte musulman ce
n'est absolument pas la question il ya
effectivement l'exercice du culte
musulman qui doit se respecter
comme tout autre culte et ça c'est un
point d'honneur et d'art le président de
la république l'a rappelé dans son
discours
maintenant il
s'agit là de mettre le doigt sur des
choses qui nous pose problème
aujourd'hui dans notre société et les en
plus impopulaire que pleuvaient les rois
pour être les craies pour être très
proche de cette question là dans son
ensemble et être élu d'un territoire
haussier concernés par cette question
les fidèles même nous interpelle sur ces
questions est aujourd'hui de guérande
est un problème n'existe pas sur
l'ingérence des pays étrangers vous avez
ça n'existe pas c'est très dur est de
dire des choses et rien qui nous sommes
pour dire attention il ne faut pas
stigmatiser une population mais c'est
exactement ce que va dire le président
eric haïk moi mais je n'ai pas du tout
dit ça je voulais vous voulez dire
pardon parce qu'on désire mais pardon
mais ça vous fait du repos non mais
parce que juste machin l'accord en
disant soumise qu elle s exprime sur
elle et assure se tape derrière il y a
tout de suite un cabinet libéral tromper
mais je ne supporte plus alors vous
allez vous dire madame vous allez
arrêter ça je ne suis pas s'épuiser mais
non parce que j'en ai marre de ce propos
le client tellier et parce que c'est
nous narrer parce que vous devriez
jamais non non on est là pour s'écouter
bout du tapis berbère n'est pas cet
électorat chavez il n'ya qu'un pas c'est
qu'on prélève au réveil congolais la
table mais vont porter vous dit vous ne
dites rien de présenter l'accord de tous
à bâle deuxièmement je vais vous dire
non mais j'en ai aujourd'hui ce que fait
en marche c'est venir à quatre semaines
des élections venir parler de ça et dès
que évidemment des jeunes comme moi même
qui donnait dire 'attendez lot de
bonheur
vous veillez à supporter les clés de
toute façon il y avait de sauvegarder un
mini film à la répu la balance entre et
le mécénat dans les sous ni notes
exprimé à plurien fond non mais c'est ce
que je suis en train de vous dire
maintenant le président s'est à
plusieurs reprises exprimé sur cette
question il a dit qu'il allait attendre
et c'est une question qui est assez
complexe pour ça il a consulté des
experts et la consulter des élus la
consulter des parlementaires et l'a
consulté beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sur
cette question id
il a lu les rapports parlementaires a
laissé rouler il maintenant tout va il a
pris son pion et non c'est à dire mais
oui parce que parce que parce que c'est
un sujet aujourd'hui qui est ce qu'il a
dit sur le fond
mais le fond ça leur cas ok je vais vous
les citez alexis corbière vu que vous
voulez le fond c'est en quatre points
reprendre le contrôle et lutte contre
les influences étrangères s'est autorisé
une meilleure méthode d'organisation du
culte musulman longue lutter avec
détermination contre toutes les
manifestations de séparatisme islamistes
et du repli communautaire et enfin à la
ramener la république dans les quartiers
parce que c'est ce n est qu un gilet
quitte à l'évidence ils s'avouent un ce
que vous dit georges makoun ou alors
elle joue comme il aime à parler s'il
vous plaît les remords bière c'est mon
bras mains tout petit peu local vraiment
et tout le monde est très charmant temps
de la berge il veut passionnant les
échanges contradictoires et je viens là
pour apprendre des choses
je n'ai pas d'opinion péremptoire là
dessus et je viens d'apprendre avec
plaisir que il a traité quatre thèmes
dont le dernier ma part est le plus
important probablement celui qu'il
traitera le moins profondément mais mais
pardon de fait de cheveux gracieuseté je
suis frappé déjà par le fait qu'ils nous
a fait languir tout de même il nous a
annoncé à intervalles réguliers vous
l'avez très bien dit une annonce
importante des discours et à force de
l'annoncer on croyait qu'ils ne
viendraient plus est en réalité elle est
arrivée je trouve déjà que cela est
positif
alors les quatre thèmes qu'il évoque me
paraissent je n'aurais pas mauvaises
grâces en disons qu'il est inutile de
d'avoir des engagements pour changer par
exemple les influences étrangères je ne
crois pas que ce choix
une bonne méthode dans notre république
mais j'espère que ça ne ressemblera pas
à la multitude des engagements que
droite et gauche confondues depuis des
années nous ont annoncé en cherchant à
faire passer c'est bref pour de l'action
et en abandonnant précisément
concrètement la reconquête que doit
faire la réplique dans les quartiers
j'ai très peur que ça ressemble encore
un verbe qui sera frappé dîner
festivités et qui n'arrive pas par
hasard à la profond que vous l'entendiez
ce procès-là ce reproche là parce que il
n'est pas le seul un philippe bilger à
le faire eric diard aussi trouve que
cela trop dur
trop duré mais bon les quatre phrases
c'était des phrases slogan est alors on
risque d'être déçu
moi je veux revenir sur les pointes dont
vous avez parlé et meyer les imams
consulaires là c'était un point
d'intérêt c'est concret n'est pas
intéressant et l'afrique et nous alors
ce sont des imams qui arrive de certains
pays qu'avec d'algérie 15,2 maroc qui
arrivent de tunisie qui arrive d'arabie
saoudite qui sont donc importer et qui
souvent ne parle pas la langue française
et donc ça pose vraiment un problème et
donc mettre fin à cette saisie montre
donc ça me paraît être une bonne chose
mais la suppression des mêmes que ceux
d'hier des imams formés en france
né en france des imams nom des imams en
tout cas les imams formés enfin alors il
dit il faut une structuration il
appelait ça l'imamat après ils renvoient
la balle
le solo conseil français du culte
musulman en dix ans j'attends des
propositions
là je reste un peu plus circonspect je
resterai là dessus sur le conseil
français du culte dans la formation des
imams et l'organiser il a demandé au
conseil français du culte musulman de
faire des propositions pour lutter fiq
efficacement contre les courants
extrémistes
il a pas parlé de l'imam consulaires
pour les renvoyer la balle
il aimait de l'athlète josé des
magiciens des marlins à vue il a dit que
progressivement parce que ça peut pas se
faire du jour au lendemain évidemment
mais que progressivement on allait
justement diminuer là on a vu des cars
minoritaire il faut le dire extrêmement
minoritaire de certains imams qui
prêchait la haine et et qui parfois sont
expulsés pas systématiquement mais
l'homme est de placer les forumeurs quoi
les normes et les formes et 11 dans des
huiles dans lesquels les données
existent déjà ou 0 logique qu'on avait
aujourd'hui une école qui forme du côté
d'evry et qui est en partenariat avec
l'université d'evry qui forment désaveu
dire que l'état l'a aussi à son mollet
alors est par contre c'est son droit de
regard jusqu'à ce jeu était financée par
des fonds étrangers et aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut c'est que le financement se
trouvent au sein même de nos territoires
et comment aujourd'hui on finance le
culte musulman sans influence étrangère
mais ça existe déjà et est donc en
collaboration partenariat avec
l'université d'evry me tâte pour
justement que les imams soient formés
georges malbrunot je voudrais
leur et les lois de la république
comprenne un tout petit peu de recul
avec vous pour essayer de comprendre ce
fondamentalisme islamique
il ne menace pas du tout que notre pays
c'est non non c'est beaucoup plus large
pour pourquoi pas ce qu'on parle des
puissances étrangères on parle des imams
formés à l'étranger qui viennent pour
essayer de donner c'est évidemment que
ce problème est un problème général on
l'a en allemagne ont là aussi en italie
c'est plutôt des pays qui ont agi avant
nous on a quand même été un petit peu en
retard nous il ya un point sur lequel
lorsqu'on est on a fait le tour un petit
peu d'un ensemble de villes et de
mosquées en france qui était financée
par par qatar charity on l'a vu aussi
des élus locaux qui étaient quand même
un petit peu complète on y vient un peu
là dessus je crois que c'est un autre
élément est un terreau ces élus locaux
ils ont à leur disposition des gens du
renseignement territoriales qui sont des
gens dans le job c'est d'aller écouter
d'aller un filtre et ils le font souvent
très bien eh bien il faut qu'il y ait
plus de coordination entre air les coins
d' aveuglement ou dans les danses jeux
parisiens wismes de clear2pay ont-ils
envie d'être réélu alors à mulhouse vous
avez 30 % de de population qui est de
confession musulmane à roubaix c'est
encore plus ce sont des gens qui veulent
et c'est normal mais je crois qu'à un
moment donné il faut que les maires il
soit il faut qu'il se passait des parce
qu'en face pape saignements responsables
les enfume un petit peu justement
latéraux ces départs et oriane est à la
disposition de ces gens sur le
clientélisme sur le rôle des élus est
sur une forme de complicité qu'ils ont
pu avoir et qui ne date pas d'hier
goûter gérard collomb il était chez nos
confrères de lci ce matin on a perdu 20
ans on a perdu un temps sur cette
question en interne
oui on s'est fait grignoter de fait
vingt ans sans réagir dans certains cas
oui bien sûr
on l'a fait certains parce que il y
avait une certaine naïveté
d'autre part ce qu'on pouvait s'appuyer
électoralement sur des communautés
naïveté une complicité de certains élus
les deux complicité de ces reprises et
de cette chose jugée
par exemple il est nommé jean christophe
lagarde mercredi
voilà moi je ne connais pas les six
nations mais je veux dire que ça peut
exister bien évidemment ouais mais ça
existe
oui j'arrive donc ça il faut l'éradiquer
il faut les rennais qui ont dénoncé oui
monsieur il faut désavoué ces mères bas
il faut en tout cas faire en sorte
qu'ils changent effectivement de
pratiquer ou bien que les élections
permettent de changer à l'intérieur de
la vie voilà gérard collomb fait existe
le clientélisme et on a pris 20 ans de
retard vous rejoignez ce constat il
existe dans nos têtes qu'on peut voir
jean christophe lagarde bobigny le
système mobile et le clientélisme
électoral premièrement il frappa la
gauche plutôt que la droite qui frappe
tous les partis il est traduit il
étrange il est transversale j'entends
aussi alexis corbière
ils ne il n'existe pas que pour la
communauté musulmane
je l'entends mais moi je prends un
exemple je suis allé lors de mes
auditions en préfecture de bobigny où là
j'ai rencontré tous les serviteurs de
l'état tous les serviteurs c'est-à-dire
préfet procureur recteur et qu'est ce
qu'ils m'ont dit au final après
troisième on dit attention les élus il
faut qu'il fasse attention à force et
toi avec le froid mairie les antennistes
exactement un mercantilisme et ses
séquelles comprend quatre abstentions et
qui se base sur des associations qui ne
respectent pas les valeurs de la
république
on ne vendait ce que l'état justement
regarde l'argent utilisé par les maires
dans les collectivités le clientélisme
ne vise pas uniquement le financement 9
du culte musulman est fini il est
partout sur la police agirait sur un île
et à levallois exactement fervaques
il ya certains aussi fort il fallait une
charte de laïcité c'est à dire elle
existe elle est noël existe mais il faut
le rendre obligatoire pour toutes les
collectivités lors une charte de la
qualité ça veut dire quoi
d'argent public dans une collectivité à
-2 si vous ne répondez pas un certain
nombre de conducteurs fut ne peut plus
donner quand on est maire à une
association quelle qu'elle soit ce
serait une bonne idée ça avec ses jeux
suivants je ne sais pas ce qu'en partie
les médias ne veux pas faire la
promotion du maire de boissy mais ça
semblait tellement évident il dit j'ai
apposé par tous une charte de la laïcité
lorsqu'une association ne la respecte
pas je supprime les subventions ça exigé
pour des régions également là il
apparaît un peu trop drastiques où il
faut clarifier aussi éviter le mélange
des genres vous avez dans certaines
mosquées etc du cultuel qui se
juxtaposent au culturel alors là
simplement parce que le cultuel dépens
de 1905 dont on ne peut pas le financer
quand vous avez à côté une salle de
classe des ce1 des centres commerciaux
culturels et là vous pouvez être
financés donc là il faut clarifier tout
ça il ya une opacité extrêmement grande
dans tous les bars et un sens de la fin
avec ces corps bien la star vient de
dire est fondamentale
le culturel et dans la rue centre
cultuel et culturel mais oui pendant que
la cathédrale d'evry a été financée de
l'argent public parce qu'il y avait un
petit musée l'histoire du catholicisme
et on a fait ça aussi certainement
j'étais comprendre l'institut pardon
quand il s'appelait de l'islam à paris
tout est contre 7 et bertrand delanoë
parce qu'il y avait un lieu culturel
mais il y avait des salles de prière et
ont financé et ce mélange n'est pas bon
moi je répète les fidèles se payant
leurs lieux de culte pas de financement
public un moment vraiment juste dermot
parce que je voulais avoir votre regard
des luttes internes menées sur ces
livres qui sortent et ses reportages et
ses enquêtes en ce moment qui concerne
en partie votre département mais
certaines villes
bobigny aubervilliers didier daeninckx
que vous connaissez qui auteur de polar
très attaché à ces villes communistes
qui a fini par en sortir elle chefs tels
le maire et les barbares sur sur le
système à bobigny c'est bien que ça
sorte le 93 mois il était temps vous
êtes tandis qu'une famille je vous pose
des questions chaque enquête soit
rigoureuse et vous évoquez c'est pas
toujours le cas
c'est pas toujours le cas il ya du
sensationnalisme avec des histoires qui
sont réglés depuis 15 ans et à mélanger
des des choses donc premièrement
attention à ce que certains ne viennent
pas faire un tour de piste pour dire des
ne rien apporter de nouveau deuxième en
moi comme élu j'ai demandé au préfet il
est prêt à le faire mais vous évoquez
les services de l'état ne nous aide pas
toujours comme élu quand on pose des
questions moi je le vois en seine saint
denis non mais de savoir si telle ou
telle association etc
je pense qu'on pourrait aller aller plus
statut et puis après je le répète on est
on part de la seine saint denis mais y'a
un rapport parlementaire avait conclu
là-dessus qui dit que la
seine-saint-denis en terme d'écoles
d'hôpital de plein de choses
elle est sous-doté et vous pouvez pas ne
pas faire un lien entre le développement
de l'obscurantisme religieux et le fait
que la république a fortement reculé
exact effet quand même ça le fond du
problème du tout la république l'égalité
serait d'accord sans compter exactement
dans le plan du président de la
république où il annonce vraiment allée
des faudra attendre pour le volet on va
mais aussi le retourneur avec un geek
dans les quartiers maison qu on sera
d'accord sur les tarifs gouvernementaux
quasiment au compost au capes d'arts à
nola vous repartez mais cette spirale
c'est vrai c'est un vrai sujet c'est le
sujet si vous vous pour éviter qu'on
apprenne l'arabe dans les mosquées il
faut accentuer les échos actuellement
important que vous avez rajouté à ce
débat on s'arrête là philippe bilger
vous savez ce dont parlent tous les
députés quand ils ne viennent pas sur
lcp des retraites
où en est-on dans le marathon des
retraits l'état d'énervement de voir
entre elles deux autres y venir et bien
on y va
[Musique]
bonsoir ces familles alors deuxième jour
de la discussion dans l'hémicycle quoi
de neuf dans cette guerre de tranchées
sur les retraites est bien ambiance
électrique dès la reprise des débats cet
après midi à peine cinq minutes de
séance et la députée et clémentine
autain dégaine un rappel au règlement
une arme classique et redoutable de
l'opposition pour ralentir les
discussions sauf que la députée
insoumise s'emmêle un peu les pinceaux
regarder un rappel au règlement sur
l'article 51 1 et qui relèvent des
propos que vous avez tenus ce matin à
l'occasion du bureau de l'assemblée où
nous avons bien noté que notre groupe
était particulièrement visée de façon
discriminante
aujourd'hui à part donc pas du bureau
pardonnez-moi de la conférence des
présidents vous avez raison monsieur le
président je m'excuse de cette erreur
oui mais vous les voulez cumulé parce
que l'article 31 alinéa ne se rapporte
pas ce que vous indiquez 20 52 2 1
et y'a pas oui non ça marche toujours
pas je suis désolé madame bon il va
falloir tout de même faire les choses un
peu rigoureusement comprenez je vais
bien recevoir tous les ponts c'est mon
corps vont dire qu'ils soient fondées
assez difficile la procédure
parlementaire compliqué ça commence fort
vous l'avez vu notamment car ce matin
richard ferrand a expliqué qu'il
appliquerait à la lettre justement le
règlement de l'assemblée nationale
objectif contrer la stratégie du ralenti
de l'opposition il n'y aura donc qu'un
orateur par groupe pour les amendements
identiques
par exemple si les 17 députés la france
insoumise dépose le même amendement un
seul à soues insoumis pourra prendre la
parole en séance
une règle qui s'appliquera donc à la
france est soumise aux communistes car
ces deux groupes ont fait un dépôt
massif d'amendements identiques et
démontre une volonté manifeste
d'obstruction selon la conférence des
présidents qui s'est tenue ce matin
alors côté calendrier pour pour terminer
ce qu'on y voit plus clair combien de
temps ça va durer on le sait personne
n'en sait rien mais l'assemblée
nationale a pris les devant les députés
vont siéger ce week-end et trois
semaines au lieu des deux prévues
initialement jusqu'au 6 mars donc
selon les calculs de la présidence et de
différents groupes dans les faits il n'y
aurait pas quarante et un mille
amendements discussions mais plutôt 5000
grâce ou à cause de l'application
stricte du règlement 1300 amendement
donc pour la france un soumise au lieu
de 23 mille déposés dans ces conditions
ça peut rentrer en trois semaines
explique t optimiste impossible réplique
les pessimistes
le gouvernement envisagerait lui de
réécrire certains articles pour faire
tomber des amendes non et donc gagner du
temps mais l'armé ultime vous le savez
c'est le 49-3 alors à la république en
marche au gouvernement personne ne veut
en parler officiellement personne
indienne en veux pas du tout elle est ce
que vous les exclus et parce que pour
l'instant personne n'a on est on est
absolument déjà la question aujourd'hui
ne se pose pas parce qu'on part du
principe que on a un texte à examiner et
qu'il ya une procédure parlementaire qui
doit être respectée avec une opposition
qui doit participer à la construction
d'un texte pour les français donc le
49-3 pour le moment il est absolument
pas envisagé et nour le moment
monté par les parents elle répondait
parce que on est vraiment né le maillot
vert ce matin on n'est pas décideur m'a
dit ça mais tout va dépendre de
l'opposition si l'opposition veut un
débat démocratique et serein sur ce
texte là pour l'enrichir à ce moment là
on n'aura pas recours aux 49 3 si
l'opposition joue le jeu de
l'obstruction sur ce qui a été le cas et
du déni de démocratie va évidemment ce
moment là comment ça pourrait se
justifier on verra un mois de l'année
donc on a dit personne n'y pense
personne n'en parle mais tout le monde y
pense et un député de la majorité me
confier tout à l'heure que quand il
croise des députés insoumis dans les
couloirs il lui glisse on va vous
pousser au 49 3 ans vous verrez affaire
à suivre
merci beaucoup philippe bilger sans
aucune transition maintenant ap
vous savez ce qu'elle révèle sport oui
kippen j'en ai beaucoup entendu pas la
fédé en bêta 6 des français ont
découvert à la faveur de la faire
benjamin griveaux le phénomène n'a pas
attendu évidemment l'abandon du candidat
en marche pour être pénalement
sanctionnée alors que dit la loi
comment était d'appliquer ce qu'il faut
aller plus loin dans le contrôle des
réseaux sociaux éléments de réponse avec
ahmed tazir merci à tous en 2007 laure
manaudou et la petite fiancée des
français ravissante radieuse et puis ce
choc post est relayée sur le web des
images d'elle nue apparaissent sur la
toile
la nageuse révélera que c'est l'un de
ses ex qui est à l'origine de la fuite
ce procédé on l'appelle le revenge pomme
la diffusion de vidéos photos intimes
sans le consentement de la personne
concernée
depuis la loi sur le numérique de 2016
le run sporn est une infraction
spécifique comme nous l'expliquent cet
avocat le fait de diffuser des écrits ou
des photos intimes
or le consentement de la personne c'est
un délit qui fait encourir
à son auteur deux ans d'emprisonnement
et 60000 euros damende donc on est
plutôt sur des échelles de peine assez
élevé pour ce type d'infraction en
matière de revenge porn il y a tout ce
qu'il faut dans la loi affirme notre
avocat le problème est ailleurs
l'année dernière près de 3000 plaintes
ont été déposées
malgré tout de nombreuses victimes
n'osent pas faire appel à la justice
vous savez franchir la porte d'un
commissariat ou une gendarmerie
lorsqu'on est à saverne lorsqu'on est à
nîmes quand on est dans le nord de la
france
et montrer des photos et dire voilà ce
qui m'arrive est parfois devant un
policier ou un gendarme qui ne sait même
pas que cette infraction existe parce
qu'on a un vrai déficit de nos
enquêteurs et de toute la chaîne pénale
sur ce qui est vaguement numérique alors
qu'aujourd'hui toute notre vie et
numérique
c'est difficile de franchir cette porte
c'est difficile mais alors est il
possible de mieux contrôler les
informations publiés en ligne
après laffaire griveaux la classe
politique s'empare du débat il ya ceux
qui disent non au nom de la liberté
d'expression mais c'est quoi à
l'améliorer c'est qu'on se sert de cette
affaire pour essayer une fois de plus d'
entraver la liberté d'expression sur
internet
une fois de plus de contraindre une fois
de plus de censurer internet
en tout cas moi j'en serais pas je vous
le dis clairement il y a ceux au
contraire qu'ils disent oui il faut
faire davantage pour lutter contre les
contenus indésirables diffusé en ligne
alors je pense d'abord s'agissant de la
régulation des réseaux sociaux et
d'internet qu'il faut rétablir la peur
du gendarme
aujourd'hui il y as en ligne une quasi
impunité et donc nous devons faire en
sorte avant même de changer la loi mais
même si on peut réfléchir à changer de
loi de faire appliquer la loi
car notre justice et la manière dont
fonctionne notre chaîne police justice
ne s'est pas adapté à ce monde du
numérique à sa viralité à sa masse face
au fléau revenge porn le mieux reste la
prudence ne pas envoyer des images de
soi même dans le cadre d'un échange
privé internet peut transformer en un
instant une affaire privée en drame
public et ils nous ont rejoints sur ce
plateau maître alain bensoussan bonsoir
vous êtes avocat spécialiste en droit du
numérique julien le bot bonsoir cette
journaliste auteur réalisateur de tous
les internet c'est un module consacré au
numérique sur arte je signale votre
livre dans la tête de marc zuckerberg
c'est chez actes sud et bienvenue à vous
françois kraus vous êtes directeur du
pôle politique de l'ifop et vous venez
tout juste de réaliser une enquête
consacrée au rival ford rendu public ce
matin je vais commencer avec vous m
haies avec vous philippe bilger jouvray
je voudrais d'abord comprendre 3000
plaintes et seulement 20 condamnations
dont depuis la promulgation de cette loi
1016 sur le rivage porn comment
comprendre c'est quelque chose qui
marche pas ou alors ya pas de preuve ou
alors ce sont des fausses plein je ne
sais pas j'ai pas j'ai pas le détail des
plaintes mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on dispose d'un système
juridique parfaitement organisée
c'est le niveau des plaintes qui me
paraît peut-être un peu faibles chances
que le système est organisée de la
manière suivante des moments vous captez
vous enregistrer sans le consentement de
la personne c'est punissable d'un an et
de 45000 euros 6,7 à caractère sexuel
ces deux ans et 60000 euros
et si vous diffusez sert un clic vaut et
que l'équivalent d'un enregistrement
c'est les mêmes peines hier qu'il y a il
ya un système judiciaire qui est
parfaitement organisés pour vous ce
système là il est suffisamment dissuasif
répressif alors pour moi il ya il ya un
déficit est un déficit de pédagogie des
émissions comme celles ci sont
importantes et un déficit de marqueurs
de la démocratie un déficit de pédagogie
la plupart des gens ont découvert que la
simple diffusion parole et d'une vidéo
étaient des mêmes peines comme si on
l'avait enregistrée ça c'est la nouvelle
loi qui vous relayer le site et vous
relayer les mails vous encore et les
mêmes peines comme si c'est le même
temps effectivement parce que ce qui est
arrivé donc aux députés joachim von
forget on rappelle l'histoire qui a
relayé donc le site de de ceux de ce
piètre pleuve pas vraiment ce qui a donc
deuxième deuxièmement c'est le marqueur
c'est à dire qu'au-delà des au delà du
déficit pédagogique est ce que 2 on
prison c'est suffisant les marqueurs de
peine sont général le bien et le mal
dans une démocratie
et puis on arrive à une situation où il
n'y a pas de neutralité technologique
ainsi si vous enregistrez sans droit ni
titre c'est un an caractère sexuel deux
ans mais si vous pirater le smartphone
en attaquant le smartphone ces cinq ans
soit tout à fait normal d'avoir une
telle différence alors que l'atteinte à
la victime est identique
ce qu'il faudrait voulait harmonisée en
fonction des techniques pour aligner
principe de neutralité technologique
protection d'un victime d'une part et
puis il faut sacraliser la démocratie
pendant la période électorale je pense
qu'il faut prévoir une circonstance
aggravante
parce que la date choisie
vous voyez quinze jours avant de telle
manière qu'il faut le remplacer
après il y aurait pas eu de remplacement
et donc il me semble qu'il ya une
détresse une stratégie de
déstabilisation et donc une circonstance
aggravante me paraissait un bon élément
de protection alors quand on dit 60000
euros deux ans de prison c'est toujours
la peine maximale vous rêver mieux vaut
mieux que moi y'a des gens qui soient en
prison
non non non non non j'ai pas d'éléments
statistiques mais je crois pas qu'elle
est désert est difficile de parler de ce
sujet devant un grand spécialiste de
tout cela et l'amateur que je suis à
moins de scrupules à dire ce qu'il pense
- vous êtes là pour ça que je crains
c'est que tout de même le débat qui se
déroule depuis plusieurs jours faire va
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain et je
sens chez certains la tentation perverse
de nier l'apport formidablement positive
d'internet et deuxième élément je trouve
que il y a quelque chose de pervers dans
notre tradition française et qui ne
concerne pas qu'internet je bois chaque
fois même dans la délinquance la plus
banale où la criminalité
lorsque quelque chose ne va pas la
tentation française est de proposer
immédiatement un changement législatif
comme si ça représentait une action au
lieu de tout simplement faire appliquer
le dispositif qui est il faut qu'il faut
pas une loi grivois ce serait lui faire
beaucoup trop d'honneur est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire on va venir sur le
numérique les critiques qui pleuvent sur
les réseaux sur les plateformes est-ce
qu'il faut sanctionner en amour en aval
comment y arriver et ce qui est c'est
souhaitable déjà sur voix sur la réalité
et les victimes qui sont elles sont des
femmes le plus souvent des hommes des
personnalités de pouvoir c'est des gens
qui se sont séparés chacun globalement
c'est des gens qui se sont séparés qui
devait avoir une vie paisible après et
que malheureusement leur histoire va
rebondir pour l'un d'entre eux est
aujourd'hui la plupart encore des
personnes qui se trouvent dans cette
situation sont poussés par des problèmes
de centimes en une sorte de crime
passionnel numérique en plus petit bien
sûr j'ai bien conscience que c'est pas
un crime c'est à un simple délit
les jeunes aussi un nom il ya beaucoup
de jeunes qui se retrouvent dans cette
situation parce crédible parce que je
crois que avec avec avec eux j'ai une
position un peu orthogonale je pense que
la dissuasion n'est pas suffisante en
terme en terme de sanction pénale
l'habit fait voilà deux ans et un an
c'est pas possible c'est trop peu c'est
trop peu les victimes facilement des
victimes non les victimes à disons trois
problèmes d'abord souvent ces sources
anonymes et les victimes ne savent pas
que il n'ya pas d'anonymat sur le net
vous et vous devez nécessairement
déposer votre identité chez l'hébergeur
c'est uniquement un pseudonyme
donc elles ne savent pas ça elle pense
qu'elles n'ont pas d'action elle pense
que c'est pas possible de retrouver la
personne et donc les abandonne ça c'est
le première première peine en la
deuxième peine c'est qu'elle ne veut pas
revivre ça une seconde fois et lors du
procès de nouveau assumer la situation
d'une deuxième atteinte à la vie privée
avec un risque bien évidemment on
imagine ont tout simplement à ses biens
a trimé c'est la double peine et parfois
la sanction de prison de 2,2 de la
personne qui est auteur de l'infraction
n'a aucun effet sur leur peine donc vous
souhaitez renforcer les sanctions mais
pas forcément de faire une nouvelle loi
je viens à vous parce que c'est un débat
collectif sur les numériques mais je
voudrais savoir qui sont ces français
qui ont déjà et c'est très intéressant
elles tombent aujourd'hui eu recours à
ces pratiques de revenge porn françois
kraus 4 % des français ont déjà pratiqué
le rugby c'est une pratique en hausse
oui qui a doublé en l'espace d'une demi
douzaine d'années ça c'est la proportion
de personnes qui disent qu'ils ont déjà
diffusé à l'insu de quelqu'un des images
intimes et mais la proportion de
victimes pour répondre à votre question
elle avait sensiblement supérieure on a
environ une personne sur huit qui a déjà
diffusé des images intimes de soi qui
déclarent avoir déjà été victimes de ce
type de comportement alors parfois c'est
juste un ex petit ami par exemple qui a
montré à d'autres des photos des images
et des fois c'est carrément une
publication sur les réseaux sociaux avec
un mal qui est souvent encore plus grand
mais les victimes sont très souvent
naturellement des jeunes s'engagent déjà
reçu des photos vidéos de personnes
14 % en ont envoyé et 34% des français
ont déjà échangé des messages coquins
par sms oui bah c'est une proportion qui
a été multiplié par 4 chez des jeunes en
l'espace de six ans donc on a bien une
banalisation de ces usages de ces jeux
sexuels virtuel il y est aussi bas un
usage de plus en plus généralisée des
smartphones et de nouvelles applications
comme stable 7 par exemple qui
permettent qui favorise les échanges
d'image à caractère sexuel et qui font
que finalement bas les comportements que
qui sont attribués à l'ancien candidat
macro nist aux municipales à paris sont
finalement rien d'exceptionnel pour des
jeunes autant des jeunes hommes de sa
génération
oui qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus étonné
d'ailleurs dans cette étude dont les
résultats vous avez même testé la
couleur politique l'âge la sexualité et
des usages des réseaux sociaux vous
arriver à des résultats contre intuitif
non globalement on voit que c'est
toujours des pratiques qui sont encore
essentiellement trait genre et c'était
beaucoup plus masculin trelly très
marquée générationnel mans c'est
essentiellement les jeunes de moins de
30 ans 35 ans qui sont concernés aussi
ceux qui affirment une part
d'homosexualité qui sont ceux des plus
gros utilisateurs des outils de
rencontres de pornographie on est sur
l'intégration du numérique dans ses
usages sociaux de sociabilité amical
mais aussi affectif
en plus on est jeune on est conscients
des risques alors pas forcément souvent
les adolescents les collégiens ont
tellement la pression du groupe social
qui font plus attention que des
personnes qui ont 25 ans 30 ans et qui
se sentant un peu à l'abri et libéré de
cette de cet entourage peuvent se
permettre de prendre des risques qui
finissent par regretter plus tard
alors on va parler maintenant des
réseaux sociaux je voudrais vous montrer
quelques quelques bons titres comme
monde et quelques citations daniel cohn
bendit disait récemment j'en ai marre
des réseaux sociaux des réseaux sociaux
ça c'était chez nos confrères de lci
eric dupond-moretti votre confrère les
réseaux sociaux sont en train de
déchiqueter de nous faire perdre notre
liberté christophe barbier
il faut réguler les réseaux sociaux et
les chinois arrivent bien à les bloquer
et ce matin sur un tout autre sujet je
voudrais vous faire écouter le nouveau
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
shin a pris ses responsabilités en
mettant en place des mesures de
confinement d'isolement très rapidement
elle pas si on circule bien je ne suis
pas sûr que ce serait possible de
réaliser tout cela dans un pays dans
lequel les réseaux sociaux seraient
ouverts voilà les dernières petites
citations bernard henri lévy ce matin
dans le point les réseaux sociaux ont
bon dos vous en pensez quoi j'ai à
l'aubade ce qui est compliqué c'est que
faut pas confondre tout à fait en fait
internet et réseaux sociaux et ce qui
est vrai c'est que l'architecturé
algorithmique le fonctionnement de ces
de ses plateformes de ces applications
qui sont utilisées elles ont vraiment
une puissance de réplication qui fait
que effectivement on des victimes une
fois de du fait que ce qu'une image
comme ça à caractère pornographique ait
pu circuler sans qu'on le sache mais
elle peut être très vite enregistré
dupliquer et j'ai presque envie de dire
adnot et âme circuler sur les internets
est donc le vrai problème de ces plates
formes là c'est qu'on a affaire à des
acteurs qui se sont accaparés un espace
on va dire relativement public comme
internet pour venir privatiser des
logiques de diffusion est vraiment
maximiser la capacité par un individu a
diffusé des images qui ne lui
appartiennent pas au dépend donc des
victimes et donc forcément encadrer et
réguler penser des relations sociales à
l'inter de cet environnement c'est
extrêmement compliqué alors justement
qu'est ce qui est fait aujourd'hui on
peut toujours bloquée dès ya des pays
qui le font d'ailleurs c'est incroyable
d'entendre les verts ont parlé de la
chine on sait que facebook ce sont le
patron facebook france laurent solly ce
matin qui a expliqué qu'il y avait une
impossibilité en a - avant même que ce
soit diffusé sur le réseau facebook
d'avoir par exemple des vidéos intimes
bloqué en revanche sur twitter c'est pas
forcément le cas bien que dans la salle
rivaux ce soit des liens qui était
relégué il ya différentes pratiques
selon que ce soit telle ou telle gaffe à
telle ou telle heure oui et à
l'intérieur de facebook vous avez déjà
facebook c'est au moins quatre
applications vous avez facebook
instagram whatsapp messenger vous avez
parfois des messages qui peuvent
disparaître par exemple sur sur un
salaire vous avez l'historie vous avez
des espaces confinés comme sur instagram
même si globalement la vie privée de
toute façon n'existe pas je pense que et
là j'ai été très sensible à ce que vous
disiez des hyper important de bien
mesurer que par delà la question de la
régulation
il ya un déficit je pense de la part de
l'ensemble du public de compréhension du
fait que nous n'avons pas de vie privée
nous n'avons plus de vie privée et que
donc effectivement s'amuser dans un
échange amical ou amoureux à produire ou
à récupérer des vidéos
donc c'est trop tard liberticide qui
ferait qu'on dirait qu'il faut
absolument que ces plateformes contrôle
tout non elles n'ont pas à contrôler
toutes les bd r pas touche à la
régulation des réseaux mais sur le plan
de la vie politique par exemple j'ai
tendance à considérer qu' il ya des
séquences de vie privée qui constitue
dans le débat public
des avancées pour éclairer le citoyen je
sais que ma position est minoritaire et
puis pour les réseaux sociaux je suis un
peu j'entends en permanence dire il faut
que les gens soient libres puissent
accomplir tout ce qu'ils veulent et par
conséquent les réseaux sociaux sont le
malheur suprême
- j'espère et ça n'est pas provocateur
que les réseaux sociaux doit être
respectée qu'on va les utiliser pour le
meilleur et que ça contraindre à
peut-être les gens à une forme de
rectitude personnels et publics
alors la moralisation des comportements
non retraite d'éducation des locations
ses vues lors dès lors qu'on ne
supprimera pas c'est qu'une formidable
avancée dans mes ya deux choses il ya
l'éducation qui est fondamentale et puis
à part vous avez ensuite la façon
d'encadrer de réguler il faut bien
comprendre comment fonctionnent ces les
entreprises qui gagnent de l'argent à
mesure qu'elle réplique donc il faut
être sûr que à des moments par exemple
d'intensité démocratique il est pas la
tentation comme ça de sueur polariser le
débat pour gagner beaucoup là-bas pour
bien comprendre votre position vous
dites c'est perdu d'avancé parce que ce
monde numérique des plateformes des
réseaux n'est pas réglable ça ne
marchera pas j'ai donc il faut
s'organiser c'est pour ça je ou alors ou
alors attention et liberté d'expression
l'égalité de régulation qu'ils soient si
possible d'ailleurs à l'échelle
européenne et non pas seulement
j'ai envie de dire locales ou nationales
à des choses
les personnels qui sont faites sur les
personnels mais vous avez encore un
immense travail qui peut être fait il
faut savoir qu'on est quand même l'un
des marchés les plus importants pour des
entreprises comme facebook donc on n'est
pas du tout donc oui elle est
intéressant d'ailleurs de voir que mark
zuckerberg souhaite finalement sécuriser
son affaire et son business quand il
appelle à la régulation c'est juste
qu'il veut construire des règles qui lui
permettront de continuer à gagner de
l'argent enfin agir c'est aussi simple
que ça et dans le même temps il faut non
pas faire fermer toutes ses boutiques
il faut trouver un une approche tout
simplement pédagogique une approche
suffisamment solides pour que dès le
plus jeune âge on puisse comprendre que
le smartphone étant partout les
environnements vidéo étant partout il
faut être prudent il faut mesurer ce
qu'on fait et c'est puis d'un point de
vue évidemment juridique et judiciaire
il est essentiel de pouvoir dissuader
les mauvais comportements
mais je pense que deux sur déterminer la
responsabilité d'aider des individus
n'est pas satisfaisant non plus tard
qu'il faut trouver un équilibre et
permettent à la fois de protéger les
individus mais de pas tomber leur est de
dissuader avec des sanctions aussi qui
pourrait avoir un rôle
et oui oui bien sûr les sur les plates
formes et sur les coupables il faut pas
toucher à la liberté d'expression à
l'est il faut pas toucher verte
élections l'internet c'est un des mots
les réseaux sociaux ont trouvé leur
avocat s'effondre liberté sécurité
dignité en fait la problématique
aujourd'hui c'est entre liberté sécurité
de mettre en place la dignité
il est temps d'accueillir monsieur
valéry brochard pour sa chronique
valérie nous raconte sa journée à
l'assemblée comme tous les soirs elle
est ou ce soir
le saviez-vous myriam parmi les 577
députés on compte 17
énarque j'en ai rencontré quelques uns
cet après midi je vais vous raconter la
suite en plateau
[Musique]
bonsoir
myriam alors pourquoi nous parlez vous
des députés énarque aujourd'hui et bien
parce que ce matin myriam frédéric
thiriez a remis au premier ministre un
rapport qui propose de remplacer l'ena
par une école d'administration publique
vous le savez en avril dernier manuel
macron annonçait la suppression pure et
simple de l'école des hauts
fonctionnaires mais 250 audition plus
tard moult échanges avec l'exécutif
les propositions évidemment sont plus
nuancés tout d'abord le rapport propose
aux candidats reçus au concours de cette
école et la magistrature police
pénitentiaire santé publique sécurité
sociale et territoriale de travailler
pendant six mois sur un tronc commun et
bien pour tout simplement mieux
collaborer ensemble
par la suite le rapport sujet suggère
également la fin du classement de sortie
et la fin de l'épreuve de culture
générale alors comme promis myrian j'ai
discuté avec deux députés énarque issu
de la même promo celle de 2004 on
commence à gauche avec brice vallot
monsieur vélo c'était comment l'ena
c'était c'était deux parties et lennar
il ya la partie où on fait des stages
sur le terrain ça c'était passionnant en
préfecture ou en ambassade ou ziti où
vous moi j'ai été à alger j'ai été à
ajaccio 2 2 stages donc ça c'était
passionnant et ensuite
je me suis pas mal ennuyé dans la partie
scolarité bon évidemment vous voyez
venir je vais donc demander s'il était
plutôt favorable à la suppression de
l'ena voici sa réponse
ben on aura besoin toujours de serviteur
de l'état qui soient des serviteurs de
haut niveau des fonctionnaires engagés
et il faudra continuer de les former en
ayant une préoccupation qui est celle de
l'égalité d'accès aux responsabilités
publiques faut bien évidemment à la
diversité du recrutement on peut
diversifier les voies d'accès et ça
tombe bien ça tombe bien myriam puisque
dans le rapport remis ce matin on trouve
l'ouverture d'une vingtaine de classes
préparatoires dit égalité des chances
une par région pour ainsi accueillir des
élèves sur critères sociaux et ensuite
leur ouvrir un concours d'entrée
spécifiques et d intégrer à hauteur de
15% des effectifs mais pour julien
aubert députés les républicains mais
aussi et énarque il faudrait aller
encore plus loin il faudrait interdire
qui est une phase préparatoire à paris
et là vous mettrez effectivement toutes
les classes préparatoires sur le même le
stade parce que évidemment à paribas
vous avez sous la main des hauts
fonctionnaires des responsables des gens
qui ont 5 5 étoiles sur le gâteau alors
que quand vous êtes à marseille voulait
faire descendre un haut fonctionnaire
ça lui prend la journée il peut pas et
les là le sujet alors évidemment je n'ai
pas pu m'empêcher de lui poser une toute
dernière question avant de le laisser
rejoindre l'hémicycle écouter est ce que
vous auriez une anecdote un souvenir
très précis de votre promotion 2004 à
nous raconter je pourrais vous raconter
le jouet emmanuel macron a perdu les
charmes de sa femme et l envoyer un mail
à l'ensemble de la promotion retourne en
ciel et terre pour la retrouver ça nous
avait beaucoup impressionné il avait
retrouvé
je crois qu'il l'a retrouvé à la fin je
le souhaite pour lui maintenant ils
avaient moyens d'en acheter une nouvelle
voilà après comme dans toute école moi
j'étais chargé des fêtes et des
événements
voilà festif donc j'ai organisé
plusieurs soirées soirées déguisées les
choses comme ça mais ce qui se fait à
l'aide
voilà on n'en saura pas plus on n'en
sait pas plus mais rien en revanche ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que la
nouvelle école du management public
devrait ouvrir ses portes à la rentrée
2022 merci valérie merci messieurs merci
infiniment célèbre désert de produits
sur le plateau des cp très belle soirée
à vous et à demain
[Musique]